really it messed you up for eight years
you were just kind of like not quite
yourself i tried to turn it off but it
was like we were always all together so
our dynamic was shaped from the show wow
so it was like you were you were
emulsified into who you were so it was
like you you you almost had to take it
on because it was so
all the time all the time you were
always reminded like all the time right
you have a mo especially when you have a
mohawk and tattoos on your head like you
can't you're that guy right away from it
you can't get away from it which is an
amazing thing and it really i think like
charlie and i said the other day i don't
think you can ever do that again it was
like a it was like a moment in time
that doesn't exist anymore it's like the
sopranos i talked to those guys and they
had a lot of the same exact
kind of deal where they were just
together all the time they go to dinners
all the time and their characters kind
of
acted like their characters